[Music]
from the Disney of Christmas specials
comes the holiday classic that makes the
whole family say man this movie is so
much weirder than I remember whatever a
dentist is I hope some day
you're the greatest Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer saddle up for a
sleigh ride based on the famous tune
about Rudolph full of other way less
catchy songs but since it's Rudolph
story after all
we thought we'd sing his famous Carol if
they were honest about what actually
happens in the film and when someone
else sees the tiny little mind explode
[Music]
no gold mine is going to be seen with a
red-nosed reindeer they send them into
exile cuz the sand is full of rage you
should be ashamed of yourself
Santa's elf slaves leave his brooding
job he'll be a dentist someday which is
clearly cold okay come here open your
mouth oh the frozen wasteland they'll
run into this boot who helps them find a
Yeti Wally
[Music]
okay okay hold on I got a stubby right
there this is nuts
none of this is from the Christmas Carol
it's just insane filler y'all turned a
simple story into like Lord of the Rings
for kids on acid don't do it their
friends do the story is the unless
useful story dad knows knows does doe fo
ste the Snowman
Lou Faro Yukon the red beard hipster The
Lion King and we want but wish you a
Merry Christmas Teenage Mutant red-nosed
reindeer at least they only stretched
the Rudolph song to just one hour long
special it's not like they sent him back
to dinosaur times to save New Year's or
something oh come on hey guys this
January's gonna be fan of preciate Ramon
so we wanted to give you the heads up
for two big announcements first up we're
letting you pick the honest trailers in
January I know you guys always pick the
trailers but sometimes we put off the
ones you really want because we don't
know how to do it or we just don't have
a reason to do them no more excuses the
month of January you're picking them and
we've put a list of 50 of more obscure
weirder movies for you to pick from and
you can go submit now by clicking this
box but that's not it
we're also bringing back fan fights so
if you're a fan of movie fights and
think you can do what we do better under
these lights now's your shot we'll be
flying down fans to Los Angeles to
compete on the show and you can submit
by clicking here so what are you waiting
for
get involved this January Fan
Appreciation Month we love you guys
Dormammu I've come to bargain for
Captain solo's life and now our feature
presentation
giggly moogly pew G pumpkin professor
pipi pipi pants
shut up braying or I'll stab you with a
q-tip trapped in honest trailer Factory
send help